so Republicans are now saying after the  midterms they want to extend the Donald  Trump tax cuts of 2017. this shouldn't  really surprise us there has been almost  no policy whatsoever for years from the  Republican party but you all know and if  you've been following politics for any  amount of time it won't surprise you at  all that one of the things they always  have time for and that somehow we always  have the money for is to cut taxes  particularly on the very rich the reason  they say we can always afford it is they  claim that it's good for the economy  however we actually have real economic  data and dozens and dozens and dozens of  peer-reviewed studies which tell us it  doesn't work cutting taxes on the rich  is not good for the economy but when all  you have is a hammer everything looks  like an ale their Hammer is cut taxes  for the rich they all look like nails  that need to be hammered